what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as we pick up with the second
half of the dimension Z story for those
of you guys who are curious as to why it
is that Sharon Carter is old and all-new
all-different marvel this explains that
and that's one of the other reasons why
I wanted to cover this is because it's
the little tidbits that sort of kick off
with this story that end up leading us
into understanding all the different
facets of what's going on with all-new
all-different Captain America Steve
Rogers now of course again will give us
a whole Hydra stuff and all that once we
cover Avengers standoff and will offer
more of an explanation or at least a
more in context based explanation once
we get to that particular story you
don't make a lot more sense once we once
we get there but the fact remains
following the conflict between jet black
and Steve Rogers what is it happening
here is jet very much finds herself
romantically interested in Steve that's
one of the crazy things is offered here
what we're basically told is that with
the upbringing that she received from
her father
Arnim Zola he kept her very isolated
away from any possibility of romantic
interest with other people around her
now a lot of this was done because of
the fact that in the eyes of Arnim Zola
romance is inherently a distraction in
the sense that it will get in the way of
actual motivation and so because of that
in order to make sure that jet black
functioned at her peak capacity there
could be no distractions
there could be no romantic interest or
any things like that and indeed that's
how she reached the level that she's at
right now is by not having any romance
at anybody now in truth a lot of that
was because of the fact that the
creatures are surrounded her were just
grotesque as hell and so there was no
chance of her ever falling in love with
those things in the first place but the
fact remains here that with Steve Rogers
his combat prowess the fluid nature of
his movements the fact that he fights
with his hardened soul is intriguing to
jet because he's as much of a warrior as
she is so it's kind of like this romance
forged in the fires of that'll kind of
situation it's a little screwed up but
it's also a little romantic to a degree
you know is one of those weird weird
little things but the fact remains Steve
is very much on a mission to regain an
en from the clutches of Arnim Zola the
problem with this is that Arnhem is
basically going to work on on and he's
going to work for the purpose of trying
to sway into his side now the way this
initially kicks off is that aren't them
basically beseeches in this is hey look
I'm your actual father I need you very
very much now in truth Arnim is just
being very manipulative that's all it is
he's just manipulate
son for the purpose of bringing him back
under his under his control now the
reason for that is because of the fact
that remembered Arnim Zola basically
plays mind games with the heroes that he
goes against specifically with Steve
Rogers because they've been enemies for
quite so quite so long with regards to
how Arnim Zola views Captain America I
would say he views them or he really
knows him as well as almost anybody and
see Rogers personal life after seeing
how he fights and seeing the things he
cares about and so on and so forth and
so by taking control of his son he can
in turn take control of Steve Rogers now
this is very Nazi oriented and that was
the nature of Arnim Zola back in the day
you know a lot of those campaigns when
he existed under the Nazis before he
eventually defected and went over to
Hydra it was this whole idea that with
the the Hitler Youth for example if you
control the parents by controlling the
kids and so by basically taking over the
son of Captain America he can sway in to
his side and then use Ian as a way to
defeat Captain America and that's
exactly what happens now what he does is
he basically uses brainwashing he
subjects Ian to non-stop images of
Captain America fighting but what he
does is he says ian is not the first
child that Captain America has taken and
used for his own purposes of course he
points to Bucky Barnes now the funny
thing about this is that Rick Remender
is kind of bringing in Edie Brubaker's
retcons
as well as the public perception of
Bucky Barnes and what I mean is that in
the old Captain America comics from the
1940s you know going into the the late
1940s really kind of the early 1950s
Bucky Barnes was just the traditional
sidekick kid he was the hero or the the
sidekick who stumbled across Captain
America changing into his uniform and
was like I will tell anybody your secret
if you make me your sidekick and the two
of them fought alongside forever and
then you know they were both kind of
captured the idea of a true Baker's
retcons came into play in a sense that
were Reba leaved previously the Bucky
Barnes had just died in the explosion of
a baron zemo's you know drone plane that
Bucky Barnes had actually been taken by
the Russians and turned into the Winter
Soldier but prior to that Bucky Barnes
was not just some kid on a military base
that came across Steve Rogers changing
into his Captain America uniform instead
Bucky Barnes had been trained in
espionage had been trained and stumped
had been trained in torture and all
different kinds of military tactics that
would allow him to gain the information
that he needed
hence Captain America was not willing to
torture because he wasn't willing to
kill Bucky Barnes was assigned to him in
order to serve as part of the invaders
but the public perception was that Bucky
Barnes was just the sidekick and that's
what Arnim Zola raps he grabs the public
perception and then broadcast it to Ian
and says everybody thought the Bucky
Barnes was a sidekick but he was just a
kid the Captain America just took and
made a sidekick of his own again
manipulating Ian tricking in into
believing certain things and of course
this also coincides with Captain America
arriving you know to confront jet black
now of course this is where Jets
loyalties begin to be torn you know
where Ian officially is brainwashed
where he's inducted into the views of
Arnim Zola and basically becomes his
henchman jet black goes the opposite way
she begins to side with Captain America
and the reason why is because of the
fact that he basically tells her look at
everything that's going on around you
open your eyes like Burnham's all is a
bad guy he's enslaving races that he's
created he's torturing them for
information you know he wants to conquer
all of reality and invade earth he is a
bad guy you have to see him for what he
is and when you do then you'll know what
road to take what path to choose now
eventually she makes this makes this
decision when Steve Rogers saves the
life of one of the innocent rocks that
have been taken by Arnim Zola for the
purpose of trying to create a new race
of soldiers trying to evolve them and
make a new race of super soldiers and so
because of the bravery demonstrated by
Captain America here jet black
ultimately sways to his side and
basically betrays her father to a degree
but remembered her loyalties are torn
she's torn between her father the man
who raised her despite the failings that
he has and Captain America who she's in
love with and so again it's really kind
of cool to see them going back and forth
to see them kind of kind of you know
missing and mashing but ultimately where
Steve Rogers begins the process of
making his way to Arnim Zola to
basically conquer him while jet black
makes her way towards freeing all the
other frocks that have been taking taken
prisoner we end up having and jump into
the fray and shooting Captain America
now again this is going to be kind of
cool because this is Rogers trying to
get his son back to his side and on the
surface Ian does not initially join him
Ian basically says look my name is
Leopold it's not Ian at the same time we
also end up finding out this entire
Citadel this base of operations is
basically just an interdimensional craft
that will
allow Arnim Zola to move from this
dimension Z into the main Marvel
Universe and begin the process of
conquering earth after amassing all
these different you know creatures that
he's created as a massive army of source
and so again what is up happening here
is that while jet black is able to free
a lot of these members of the frogs
Steve Rogers is able to finally sway his
son to his side now the cool thing about
this about what Rick Remender is doing
with this bit of a story is it's
basically kind of harkening back to
Bucky Barnes right I mean for years and
years and years Steve Rogers just
believed Bucky Barnes was dead Brubaker
brought that back and said no Bucky
Barnes was alive but he was being kept
in stasis between missions by the
Russian KGB to carry out assassinations
on behalf of the Russian government and
so because of that when Steve Rogers
finally came to the realization that
Bucky Barnes was very much alive what it
ultimately meant was that see Rogers can
now bring Bucky Barnes back to sanity
now of course what this did is it
basically left Marvel with the ability
to create some really really cool
stories with Bucky where he just kind of
went forward from knowing his memories
as the Winter Soldier and having his
memories as a sidekick of Captain
America and kind of finding his own way
in the Marvel Universe eventually
becoming the man on the wall but the
fact remains here that this is that
scenario for Steve Rogers compounded by
the fact that he views Ian as his son he
doesn't view Ian as his adopted son he
doesn't view in as a surrogate son tvz
and as his son and that's kind of the
cool thing here this is Rick Remender
bringing in the concept of like parents
who adopt kids right Neil there are
parents out there who adopt kids and
that's their child it's no one else's
child that's their child and they raised
that child as their own they teach that
child everything they believe to be
right and wrong you know that child
might as well be theirs in terms of a
biological sense it's not but it might
as well be because they're just as good
as their biological child with Captain
America it's the same way he abused Ian
as his son he raised that child from
infancy up to where he is right now
and so he's not just fighting a foe he's
not just fighting Bucky Barnes as a
Winter Soldier and then using the Cosmic
Cube you know to help him kind of
jumpstart his memories what it is
is him trying to bring his son back and
ultimately in this moment of the
teaching his son when he says I love you
Ian begins to sort of snap out of it Ian
begins to wake up and basically realizes
that Captain America really does care
about him in view him as a son
unfortunately none of it matters because
of the fact that Sharon Carter shoots
him in the neck she shoots him in the
neck and it is wild it really kind of
came out of nowhere now Sharon Carter
being here was initially just kind of
like what how in the world does she get
here well rip Remender is nothing if not
a guy who knows how to tell a damn good
story and so because of this what we end
up finding out throughout the entirety
of his time here you know time as it
passes in dimension Z is much faster
than as it passes in the main Marvel
Universe now in truth this is really
just recomendar giving himself a way out
but we really kind of knew that was
going to have to be the case right like
you couldn't ride a story about Captain
America trapped in dimension Z he
escapes and then 20 years have passed in
the real world honestly that just
wouldn't work we would have had to no
they would have had had to be some kind
of MacGuffin right like a cosmic you
would have to be years or he would have
to time travel or any number of other
things would have to be invoked in order
to set things back to rights but what
Sharon Carter says is look as soon as
you took off on that subway train and
things seemed wrong I follows you what
ended up happening is that while you
believe that you know a decade has
passed you know 15 years or somebody
that have passed in truth only thirty
minutes have passed in the main Marvel
Universe so it's almost like he was gone
for the blink of an eye half an hour and
she's caught up with him now again this
allows Marvel to kind of bring Captain
America out of dimension Z as if no time
had passed at all and keep the existing
continuity and tact because remember
this is all really just kind of leading
up to the collapse of the multiverse
it's all leading up to Secret Wars and
it's leading up to Captain America
losing the Super Soldier Serum in his
battle with iron nail and Sam Wilson
taking up the mantle and so because of
this it's a multi-faceted conflict on
different sides against Arnim Zola you
have jet-black freeing the different
frocks and then going against Arnim solo
raising an army against him at the same
time you also have Sharon Carter and
Steve Rogers going against Arnim Zola
proper now ultimately Sharon Carter's
able to pull this off but only in the
sense that she basically has to detonate
the entirety of arnim zola's dimensional
ship or whatever it is in order to
basically pull off his defeat the issue
here though is that in the process
Captain America and jet black are able
to make their escape back to the main
Marvel Universe but in the process
Sharon Carter is believed to have been
caught in the explosion
and basically left behind now the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that again for those of you guys who are
going to be getting in early I guess for
those guys who were picking up with
Captain America Steve Rogers from
all-new all-different marvel
Sharon Carter's old because of the fact
that she's been stuck in dimension Z all
this time now the reason why Captain
America didn't age is because he's got
the Super Soldier Serum he'll stay young
no matter where he is he could be in a
dimension where time travels 500 times
faster than it does in the main Marvel
Universe and he will age accordingly and
he'll still get older but he won't age
by 500 years he'll age by a fraction of
that but what Sharon Carter she's a
person she's a normal human being
15 years passed in dimension Z 15 years
passed for her she comes out looking 15
years older so because of that that's
the reason why she ends up popping out a
great deal older than she is now again
this was setting the stage we're kind of
removing Sharon Carter as a tried and
true person that could be significant in
the role of Captain America now as far
as you know my research is gone I
haven't been able to find a reason for
why Marvel would pull that off it's not
tied to the movies because Sharon Carter
and Captain America are getting together
in the movies so I mean it wouldn't
really be tied directly to that I'm not
really sure what the motivation was I
guess really it was just kind of taking
him away from the world of Captain
America putting Sam Wilson in his place
and then coming back around
jump-starting his age making him older
so that both he and Sharon Carter could
be together because then he would
eventually be to save be around the same
age as her but again it's really kind of
a mishmash of ideas a mishmash of
concepts and it works it's just really
kind of it kind of threw people off a
little bit but in any event if you guys
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb cork the guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys in
the next video peace
[Music]